PORN STAR STORMY DANIELS.
GET.
THIS THE FEDS REPORTEDLY GOT
THE SEARCH WARRANT AFTER
RECEIVING A REFERRAL FROM
SPECIAL COUNSEL BOB MUELLER.
THE PRESIDENT RESPONDING
FORCEFULLY EARLIER TODAY.
>> WE JUST HEARD THAT THEY
BROKE INTO THE OFFICE OF ONE
OF MY PERSONAL ATTORNEYS,
GOOD MAN.
AND IT'S A DISGRACEFUL
SITUATION.
IT'S A TOTAL WITCH-HUNT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A LOT
OF SERIOUS THINGS WITH THE
GREATEST FIGHTING FORCE
EVER.
AND I HAVE THIS WITCH-HUNT
CONSTANTLY GOING ON FOR OVER
12 MONTHS NOW.
AND ACTUALLY MUCH MORE THAN
THAT YOU COULD SAY IT WAS
RIGHT AFTER I WON THE
NOMINATION IT STARTED.
THIS IS THE MOST BIASED
GROUP OF PEOPLE.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE THE
BIGGEST CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST I HAVE EVER SEEN.
>> Laura: BACK TO MY
QUESTION AT THE TOP.
IS THIS A MAJOR OVERREACH OR
A STRONG SIGN THAT TRUMP IS'
ATTORNEY IS IN SERIOUS LEGAL
JEOPARDY?
A WHOLE LOT TO UNPACK HERE.
LET'S BRING IN FORMER
INDEPENDENT COUNCIL DURING
THE BILL CLINTON SOL
WISENBURG AND RNC COMMITTEE
WOMEN FOR CALIFORNIA AND
FORMER SECRET SERVICE
OFFICER, NRATV CONTRIBUTOR
DAN BONGINO.
LET'S GET WITH YOU, SOL, TO
RAID AN ATTORNEY'S OFFICE,
HOME, AND TEMPORARY HOTEL
ROOM, TALK ABOUT THE
THRESHOLD IN ORDER TO
JUSTIFY THAT TYPE OF RAID.
>> THERE IS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY AGGRESSIVE
PROSECUTION MOVE.
THIS IS CONTROLLED BY THE
U.S. ATTORNEY'S MANUAL,
LAURA.
YOU ARE ONLY SUPPOSED TO DO
IT IF LESS INTRUSIVE MEANS
LIKE A SUBPOENA ARE NOT
AVAILABLE OR WON'T WORK.
YOU HAVE TO GO TO NOT ONLY
THE U.S. ATTORNEY, THE U.S.
ATTORNEY IN YOUR DISTRICT,
THAT WOULD BE NEW YORK CITY.
BUT YOU HAVE TO CONSULT WITH
THE CRIMINAL DIVISION.
THEN THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF
RULES YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW
HAVING TO DO WITH REVIEW OF
THE MATERIAL.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS IS VERY
UNUSUAL AND IT'S EVEN MORE
UNUSUAL TO MY UNDERSTANDING
FROM THE REPORTS WERE THEY
SPECIFICALLY WERE LOOKING
FOR SOME COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
HIS ATTORNEY.
THAT MAKES IT EVEN RARER.
AND TO DO IT WHEN THE
ATTORNEY IS THE ATTORNEY FOR
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS QUITE AMAZING.
NOW, IT'S TOO EARLY FOR US
TO TELL, YOU KNOW, WHETHER
IT'S RIGHT OR WRONG OR
VALID, BUT I CAN TELL YOU IT
IS OUTSTANDINGLY AGGRESSIVE.
>> Laura: DAN, THE PRESIDENT
WAS JUST ON FIRE ABOUT THIS
TODAY.
I MEAN, I DON'T THINK I HAVE
SEEN HIM THAT MAD PUBLICLY
FOR WHAT HE SAID WAS A
WITCH-HUNT.
A DISGRACE, HE REPEATED HIS
FRUSTRATION WITH JEFF
SESSIONS, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
YOUR TAKE ON THIS?
>> WELL, LAURA, YOU KNOW,
YOU OPENED UP THE SHOW
MICHAEL COHEN IN LEGAL
JEOPARDY?
LET ME ANSWER YOU, LAURA, WE
WOULD ALL BE LEGAL JEOPARDY
IF BOB MUELLER WAS AFTER US.
MOTHER TERESA WOULD BE IN
LEGAL JEOPARDY IF BOB
MUELLER WAS AFTER US.
THE FEDERAL CRIMINAL CODE.
WE ARE ALL FEDERAL
CRIMINALS.
I PROMISE SOMEBODY PAID A
PENNY LESS IN TAXES AND IS A
FEDERAL CRIMINAL.
NO MATTER HOW GOOD YOU ARE.
THIS IS A SCAM THIS CASE IS
A COMPLETE TOTAL WITCH-HUNT.
THINK ABOUT THE DOUBLE
STANDARD.
THEY RAIDED DONALD TRUMP'S
ACTUAL ATTORNEY.
OFFICE TO GO AND GET OFFICE.
YET WHEN HILLARY CLINTON
INTERVIEWED HER STAFF WHO
WENT TO LAW SCHOOL BUT
WASN'T HER ATTORNEY, SAT IN
AS HER ATTORNEY SO THEY
COULD WINK AND NOD AT EACH
OTHER, SHE WAS ALSO A
POTENTIAL CO-CONSPIRATOR,
CHERYL MILLS, AND THEY WERE
ALLOWED TO KEEP EVIDENCE
FROM THE FBI.
THE COMPUTERS AFTER THEY
LOOKED AT THEM.
IF NOT NOT A DOUBLE
STANDARD.
YOU KNOW, JUSTICE ISN'T
BLIND, IT'S DEAD NOW AND
REALLY SAD THAT'S HAPPENING.
>> Laura: HARMID, WE WERE
TRYING TO LOOK FOR INSTANCES
WHERE THE LAWYERS MONDAY.
HAD THEIR OFFICES RAIDED.
DAN IS EXPRESSING THIS
FRUSTRATION, UNREAL TO HAVE
THE FEDS GO IN AND SEIZE A
WHOLE BUNCH OF DOCUMENTS
WITH APPARENTLY A CLEAN
TEAM, YOU KNOW, SEPARATE THE
PRIVILEGE MATERIAL OUT.
BUT BOY, TALK ABOUT CHILLING
A RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN A
CLIENT AND HIS OR HER
LAWYER.
IF THIS IS WHAT THE FEDS
NEED TO DO, TO GET THE GOODS
ON SOMEONE.
YOUR REACTION AS A
PRACTICING CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY?
>> LAURA, THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS
AND UNPRECEDENTED.
I SAID IT ON YOUR SHOW
BEFORE.
CONSERVATIVES HAVEN'T PAID
ENOUGH TO THE RIGHTS
GUARANTEED BY THE FOURTH
CONSTITUTION AND TO SEIZE
ANY ATTORNEY'S
COMMUNICATIONS WITH HIS
CLIENT ARE OUTRAGEOUS.
I CAN TELL YOU AS A LAWYER
WHO HANDLES TRADE SECRET
CASES SOMETIMES.
YOU GO TO THE U.S.
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
DID YOU GO TO THE FBI AND
REPORT IT, IT'S HARD TO GET
THEIR ATTENTION, IS HE LEARN
I DON'T ACT AS QUICKLY AS.
THIS THEY ARE GIVING
EXTRAORDINARY ATTENTION TO
THIS.
THE TIMING OF THIS IS NOT
ACCIDENTAL AS THE OTHER
GUESTS HAVE MENTIONED.
I THINK THAT THE FACT THAT
THE IG'S REPORT IS COMING
OUT SOON, THE FBI, THAT MAY
GUARANTEE SCRUTINY.
MAYBE THIS TEAM WANTS TO
DISTRACT AWAY FROM THAT THE
OTHER THING IS THE PRESIDENT
IS EXPOSED RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
IS HE MISSING ONE OF HIS
LAWYERS AND HE HAS BEEN
LOOKING TO HIRE NEW COUNSEL.
WHO WANTS TO BE THE LAWYER
WHO HAS THEIR LIFE DISRUPTED
BECAUSE THEY HAPPEN TO
REPRESENT A CLIENT AND
WHETHER IT'S THE PRESIDENT
OR NOTMENT.
>> Laura: GREAT POINT.
>> WHO IS IN THE CROSSHAIRS
OF THE FBI.
THIS IS A CHILLING EFFECT.
THIS IS THE SAME FIELD
OFFICE OF THE FBI AND THE
SAME U.S. ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
THAT DIDN'T LIFT A FINGER
AND DIDN'T DO A THING ON THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION WITH
ALMOST BILLION DOLLARS
FOREIGN MONEY POURING
THROUGH THERE THE DOUBLE
STANDARD IS STAGGERING.
THIS IS POTENTIALLY A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS BEING
SET UP HERE.
UNPRECEDENTED.
NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE IT.
>> Laura: I HAVE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE IT.
BEEN AROUND HERE A LONG
TIME.
ATTORNEY, SOL, THE PRESIDENT
TODAY, I HAVE KNOWN HIM FOR
QUITE SOME TIME.
I WANT TO PLAY A SOUND BITE
FROM WHAT HE SAID, CAMERAS
ROLLED IN.
LET'S WATCH.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL MADE A
TERRIBLE MISTAKE WHEN HE DID
THIS AND WHEN HE RECUSED
HIMSELF OR HE SHOULD HAVE
CERTAINLY LET US KNOW IF HE
WAS GOING TO RECUSE HIMSELF.
AND WE WOULD HAVE USED A --
GENERAL IN.
SO HE MADE WHAT I CONSIDER
TO BE A VERY TERRIBLE
MISTAKE FOR THE COUNTRY YOU
AND YET THE OTHER SIDE DO
NOT EVEN BOTHER LOOKING.
AND THE OTHER SIDE IS WHERE
THERE ARE CRIMES.
AND THOSE CRIMES ARE
OBVIOUS.
>> Laura: AGAIN, TALKING
ABOUT THE DOUBLE STANDARD.
SOL, HE SEEMS TO BE
REPORTEDLY MORE ANGRY AT
SESSIONS AND ROD ROSENSTEIN
THAN HE IS AT MUELLER.
I MEAN, MUELLER IS JUST
SPECIAL COUNSEL TRYING TO
FIND CRIMES OR EVIDENCE OF
CRIMES.
PUSHING THE ENVELOPE.
BUT HE WILL NOT LET GO JEFF
SESSIONS, BOTH APPOINTING
ROSENSTEIN I THINK AND THEN
RECUSING HIMSELF FROM THIS
WHOLE MATTER.
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK THOSE
COMMENTS MAKE MUCH SENSE.
REMEMBER, WHAT MUELLER DID
HERE AND I AGREE, IT'S
EXTRAORDINARILY AGGRESSIVE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S
OUTRAGEOUS OR NOT.
AND WHAT MUELLER DID HERE,
ACCORDING TO THESE REPORTS,
HE DID WAS TO GO TO
ROSENSTEIN AND SAY WE HAVE
FOUND SOMETHING HERE.
WHO DO YOU WANT TO HANDLE
IT?
AND ROSENSTEIN SAID YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO HANDLE IT, I'M
GOING TO GIVE IT TO THE
OFFICE WITH JURISDICTION.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
INDICATION THAT MUELLER DID
ANYTHING IMPROPER UNLESS YOU
THINK IF HE STUMBLES ACROSS
SOMETHING THAT LOOKS LIKE A
CRIME HE SHOULD FORGET ABOUT
IT AND NOT TELLING ANYBODY
ABOUT IT IT'S VERY
AGGRESSIVE, YES.
IT'S NOT TOTALLY
UNPRECEDENTED.
IT'S EXTREMELY AGGRESSIVE.
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
OUTRAGEOUS YET.
LAURA, YOU KNOW, THEY HAD TO
GO TO A JUDGE AND HAD TO SAY
TO A JUDGE.
>> Laura: WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
JUDGE, DO WE?
DO WE KNOW WHAT JUDGE SIGNED
OFF ON THE WARRANT.
>> THEY HAD TO GO TO A
MAGISTRATE AND SAY NOT ONLY
IS THIS PROBABLE CAUSE OF A
CRIME AND BY THE WAY THERE
IS NO FOURTH AMENDMENT
VIOLATION HERE.
AND THERE ARE NO SPECIAL
RULES FOR ATTORNEYS UNDER
THE FOURTH AMENDMENT.
BUT THEY HAD THIS ALMOST
CERTAINLY WOULD HAVE HAD TO
HAVE SAID CRIME FRAUD
EXCEPTION APPLIES OR THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
EXPLICITLY LOOK AT
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN MIKE
COHEN AND PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SO, THEY WILL BE JUDGED.
IF THEY ENDED UP LYING IN AN
AFFIDAVIT TO A FEDERAL
MAGISTRATE, THEY KNOW THIS
IS A VERY SERIOUS THING.
>> Laura: WHAT IS THE
RECOURSE FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP
IF HE OVERSTEPPED THE LINE
AND THIS IS WHAT HARMID WAS
GETTING TO, I THINK.
IF HE OVERSTEPPED THE LINE
AND MAYBE THEY HAD PROBABLE
CAUSE I GUESS TO BELIEVE
THAT MICHAEL COHEN WAS
SHREDDING DOCUMENTS.
TO HAVE TO WORK.
SO THEY HAD TO GO DO THE
RAID, I DON'T KNOW.
THERE IS NO RECOURSE HERE IN
THE POLITICAL CONTEXT.
I THINK THAT'S THE POINT.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THIS CASE
EVEN MORE DIFFICULT.
>> THERE IS EVEN LESS
RECOURSE NOW BECAUSE IT'S
BEING CONDUCTED NOT BY
MUELLER, WHO HE CAN FIRE BUT
BY THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT IN
NEW YORK.
HIS OWN.
>> Laura: BINGO.
>> OWN PRESUMPTIVE APPOINTEE
IN THERE EVEN HARDER FOR HIM
TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT NOW.
>> Laura: 10 SECONDS EACH.
DAN AND HARMID.
DAN FIRST AND THEN HARMID.
>> SOL, I LOVE YOUR
COMMENTARY YOU ARE ALWAYS
LUCID ON THESE TOPICS BUT
YOU ARE WRONG.
THIS IS ABOUT PRINCIPLE.
THEY ARE NOT TARGETING A
CRIME HERE, THEY ARE
TARGETING TRUMP.
THIS WAS STARTED TO
INVESTIGATE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION THAT NEVER
HAPPENED.
EVERYONE ON THIS PANEL WOULD
BE A CRIMINAL IF THEY WERE
TARGETING YOU INSTEAD OF A
CRIME.
>> Laura: HARMEET?
>> I PAY MY TAXES.
>> THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO
LOOK A LITTLE CLOSER TO
HOME.
HE HAS HAD A LOT OF BAD
ADVICE FROM THE BEGINNING
ADMINISTRATION LEGAL ISSUES
AND LEGAL APPOINTMENTS.
I THINK THIS WHOLE IS AN